i feel like and i'm going to say this
out of pure love for both you comedians
because you guys are two of the best
comedians
you and for you look like fortune
feedster with a haircut and
jacked and goodness and full face yeah
fortune yeah dude put them next to you
can we do you mean fortune themes
look at you you look like he looks like
a crossfit fortune feamster yeah like
cross fortune yeah across foreign yeah
dude i i know man at least she's married
and i'm not she's married she's married
she got married right she got married
she has a diamond i'm pee
oh really fortunate female dude imagine
having to work go to work every day with
tom papa how much else talk about bread
top pop naked sourdough shout out tom
papa love love tommy p i thought tom
passed he didn't no no tom papa's alive
dude
i could see me looking like fortune holy
[ __ ]
no but you got to get a zoo
that one yeah look that one that went
down no one yeah there you go yeah feels
back theo's back spot on dog yeah dude
what are you doing there [ __ ] trump
rally what's going on there no that was
me i was hosting something for yeah some
[ __ ] uh some jeans company that was
outside the streets in manhattan and
let's just be honest in the back if you
look and the three people behind chris
if you put all of them together that is
michael jackson
those people yeah but you can't you miss
one ingredient
you don't get michael jackson dude
yeah dude but you guys all three look at
that dude yeah that's yeah i look like a
pizza
you look like a uh like why are you so
serious dog what was this for you look
like a concert you look like a a hostess
at [ __ ] como's bathroom dude yeah
[Music]